[Music]
[Music]
hello good morning just nice to see you
my name is mundo gus lukagulas i'm from
lithuania national radio and television
and i have a question on migration and
belarus in particular uh just some
context lithuanian foreign minister says
that eu negotiations with lukashenko are
the fact of happening and it's
dangerous to negotiate with a dictator
uh
so in relation to that i have two
questions so first of it's uh yesterday
you said that the commission is due to
hold technical talks with belarus so
could you just tell us a little bit more
about the content of these talks and uh
whether the eu is ready to sacrifice
some sanctions
or strong position about belarus actions
for humanitarian reasons and the other
question is that we are hearing some
reports that some countries are vetoing
sanctions to belarus national airlines
so does the commission
still stand firm for sanctions for
airlines such as bellavia belarus
national airlines that help to get
migrants to the eu border
because you've stated that before thank
you
thank you very much mindagas for these
questions and for giving me the
opportunity to um to clarify the
situation um as
we have said clearly yesterday
there is no question of negotiating with
the lukashenko regime
and what we have announced yesterday is
that we will hold technical talks
um with
the
u.n agencies and in particular unhcr and
iom
and um
the
belarusian counterparts in order to
facilitate
the repatriation of people who are
at the border that is the focus of of
the talks as well of course as
continuing to try to facilitate uh
humanitarian uh aid
to people who are
at the border in belarus that is the
only thing that we have announced
yesterday there is no question of any
type of negotiation with the lukashenko
regime
on your question related to sanctions
absolutely nothing
has changed our position remained
exactly the same as it was
before
when it comes to sanctions concerning
belarus
you have a follow-up
yeah just a quick one could you just
clarify once again what is the
commission's position on sanctions and
in particular to the uh bellavia belarus
national airlines thank you
i will ask peter to provide you with the
details on this thank you
the position is very clear and was
formulated or outlined by foreign
ministers of all 27 member states for
the last time during their um foreign
first council this monday and the
position is that they agreed on
enlarging the scope of existing
sanctions against belarus also to
include those who are participating
those people and entities who are
participating in this illegal and
inhuman practice of human trafficking
and instrumentalizing of the migrants
now the work is being finalized in the
working group among the member states
about the concrete listings that means
finding agreement and final
final outline of the list of those who
will be sanctioned these discussions as
always are taking place among the member
states in the council in the atmosphere
of confidentiality and we never disclose
any details about ongoing discussions
about who will be or who might be on
that sanctions list
thank you
are there other questions on this issue
yes please
joseph
estonian public broadcasting
i would like to ask a question about the
calls that chancellor merkel had with mr
lukashenko
could you tell me if there was any
mandate given to the chancellor merkel
to um to represent the eu
anyway on this calls
the european union is really not in the
business of giving mandates to member
states member states
obviously have bilateral contacts
with
anyone they wish that is absolutely
normal
in
diplomacy obviously there are very close
contacts at all times between
the european commission and the various
eu member states
any other question
on this for us today
that is not the case um let us therefore
see if there are other questions related
to foreign affairs since peter is on the
podium so please only keep your hand
raised if your question is on foreign
affairs
yes
haley i think
khalid amit faruqi from geo television
news
day before yesterday a doctor and
two traders have been shot dead in fake
encounter in jammu and kashmir indian
held kashmir
and
inquiry of obviously have been announced
but
uh
506 inquiries
have been announced
on fake counters till now
but only one was conducted this is the
indian
security forces conduct in indian
occupied kashmir what you have to say
about
you are having a human right dialogue
format within the summit which was which
took place in porto portega last time
where are we on human right with india
thank you very much
so this is actually more for nabila
nabila
thank you khalid for your question a
look on the incident itself that you're
referring to i i will have to check
because i don't have the information
but as but i would like to recall our
our position in general which is that we
follow developments in jammu and kashmir
closely and that the eu's consistent
position worldwide is that allegations
of human rights violations be
investigated in line with the
international human rights commitments
wherever they are committed
thank you other questions
on foreign affairs for us today
i see only one hound raised celine
[Music]
what's your comment on the dutch
journalist working in greece and was
attacked and then advised to leave the
country following your questioning of
the pushbacks at a press conference with
the greek prime minister thank you salin
i'm afraid this is not a question on
foreign affairs
um let me see if there are other issues
related to foreign affairs before we
move to your question
that is not the case so
um i believe that would be for christian
if we have any comment to make
no
okay we will
we will have to look into this and we
will come back to you if we have any
information
here
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
hi eric um i'd like to know if taking in
account the new rules that belgian
government has approved yesterday to
constrain the virus on all the
infections spreading in in europe
i guess the european commission is
planning to change
something about its meetings the
briefings or
the press conferences thank you so when
it comes to
to your presence in the press room um i
think that the first thing to say is
that obviously your employers
will be normally
you know taking measures vis-a-vis your
working conditions and your tele-working
which means that here in the press room
normally um we should not see a major
influx of journalists and indeed if i
look at the presence that we've had
every day and today in particular we can
see that social distancing rules can
easily
be respected
and invite you to to do so by using all
of the available
all of the available space
when it comes to the commission
obviously we have seen what are the
rules um that have been
decided by the belgian authorities and
we will be looking into it but mata can
provide you perhaps with a bit more
detail
i don't know why i'm confusing all the
first names starting with m
so as ballast has repeatedly said in the
podium today i'm replacing him the
safety of our staff is of our utmost
importance and we have been implementing
very successfully since the beginning of
the pandemic
an adjustment of our ways of working to
uh to be fully operational despite the
circumstances
we have always followed and we continue
to follow the host country's
recommendations on safety and health in
this context in belgium we will ask our
staff to telework four days a week from
monday as it was decided yesterday these
measures of course will not apply to the
critical staff and stuff to which
teleworking is incompatible and we will
continue to maintain all the strict
rules on physical distancing and wearing
of face masks in all commissioned
buildings
in line with the rules in place
on this
my taste
yeah it might be a very blunt question
but if we show up more than one day in
the week
at this mid days um are we being told to
to leave the room then
mates again
you have an employer right and your
employer normally should be telling you
what are the rules that you should that
you should respect
um therefore
we count on the fact that people will be
responsible
in
how they apply the rules of the host
member state we are not a control
organization
um it is for
each employer to decide and to implement
implement the safeguard measures which
are put in place by the uh by the
belgian government
as far as we are concerned we have put
in place a dual system and that since
the beginning of the pandemic
um both virtual and physical which
therefore gives you
all of the means that you need to
respect um the rules uh as they have
been set by the belgian authorities
any other questions on this issue
i see two hands raised um yes mata you
have a follow-up on this
yeah it's okay uh it's about coronavirus
um i don't know if
i should yeah hold on let's let's focus
first on
uh the issues related to commission
working practices i see that roman no
okay there is no further hand raised
on this so thank you very much now we'll
pass the floor to romana who had been
asking the floor
for um for some time
yes go ahead yes go ahead okay
i had a question on the digital
certificate uh
there's a rumor that it will be
there will be a little expire after 12
months can you tell me something more
about that
thank you romana
it's we don't deal with rumors there are
actual facts when it comes to the
validity of the regulation on the uh
european digital kaveed certificate and
christian will be happy to refresh your
memory
yes hello good afternoon thanks for your
question
um indeed the
um as eric just alluded to
uh first of all uh let me clarify that
the the regulation uh as such
on the digital copy certificate is is
limited in time
for for one year
with the possibility uh to to prolong it
and we have
already said that we we are looking into
this and that we will
look into a possible
prolongation
also in the context of the of the next
implementation report
that we are going to do
three months before it expires but this
is of course something that we are that
we're looking into but in principle the
regulation is is limited to one year
with the with the option of being
prolonged
but i think where this um
well while i cannot comment on your
rumors or
for speculation but of course there we
had these discussions before in the
context of the question of
um of the validity of vaccination
certificates
and
what i can say there maybe also to
further clarify
is that um our euros on the digital
coverage certificate currently do not
foresee
expiration of vaccination certificates
our aim remains very clear we will
continue to facilitate
safe free movement
and a coordinated approach
across the eu
on the acceptance of the covet
certificates for travel
within the european union
discussions on ensuring a coordinated
eu approach to free movement and
continuing this approach
are ongoing and we are currently
discussing this with the ecdc and emma
as well as with member states
on the way forward
the commission is currently preparing an
update
of the applicable rules namely a
revision of the free movement
recommendation
and this will include
also elements in relation to the
validity
of the vaccination certificates and you
can expect this quite soon
as regards the domestic uses of the
certificate i think there we have been
we have been clear enough that you also
need to
distinguish between travel
[Music]
travel between member states and
domestic uses
thank you very much are there other
questions on this oh man you have a
follow up
next week or this month
sorry we didn't get that's the beginning
of your question
said
you can expect an update on the
regulation this uh quite soon would that
be this week
i was taking an update on the
recommendation
and i was saying very soon and i will i
will stay with that
romana you need to remember that the
the framework the regulatory framework
in this context
contains various elements you have a
regulation
that defined
basically
the
fundamental traits of the european
digital kovid certificate
so that we have one unified
technical solution across the eu
in order to facilitate
travel
by having one technical standard
basically when it comes to the
information related to
the health situation of european
citizens who want to travel whether they
are fully vaccinated
whether they have recently done a test
or whether they are recovering from
kovid and therefore have
antibodies so that's the regulation then
you have a recommendation
from
the
commission
that um that relates to the underlying
health
elements of um
of
what vaccination means etc etc christian
can provide more details and then you
have a third recommendation which
relates to travel from third countries
and we have always been describing
these various elements as a sort of
overall package but each of the elements
has its role to play and its its
specific its specificities obviously a
regulation as you know is binding on
on member states which is not the case
of recommendations so you need to always
take into account these differences
between the different texts
all right any other questions on the
european
digital kovite certificate
that is
not the case
so we will go to the other dimensions
related to health situation
uh hi uh i know that national uh
measures are national uh i mean sorry
health measures are national competence
but considering the the spread of the
virus all around europe and the
different measures that different
countries and governments are adopting
and i wonder if the european commission
should intervene to try and coordinate
these different measures in whole europe
thank you well this is a question for
stefan there is already a lot of
coordination taking place martha we
since the beginning of the pandemic
and the commission has been active with
member states in terms of of
coordinating this but i let stefan
remind you of the details
um thank you very much you're absolutely
right to start your question with the
fact that vaccination policies the
design implementation of vaccination
policies is a national competence so but
obviously it is also important that we
can assure a coherent and coordinated
approach at the european level
and this is indeed one of the reasons
why there's several mechanisms that have
been put into place such as for instance
the health security committee which is a
committee bringing together
representatives from the different
health ministries where they bring to
the table common challenges concerns
questions
approaches that they intend to follow
that they would like to discuss with
each other the state of play of a
vaccination and so on so we have a an um
a very strong i would say coordination
mechanism that helps us to do this of
course there's also the political level
with meetings of health ministers the
fact that commissioner kiyakidis is
offering different he's offering strong
political support by going through these
member states where we see for instance
higher
or still challenges to increase the
different vaccination rates
and there is also obviously in the
context of this working together
the civil protection mechanism which can
be triggered whenever a member state
feels the need to have support from
other member states and this is a
mechanism that has indeed been used
already uh several times in in this
context thank you
and let me remind you that we have
consistently passed the message and will
continue to pass the message on the
importance of getting vaccinated
as the first most important measure and
secondly
respecting the health safety measures
that have been recommended in particular
by the european medicines agency so
obviously
it is clear that it is important for
everybody to stay focused on ensuring
maximum vaccination rates across europe
but also
that we all continue to be rigorous in
our application of safety measures and
i'm very happy to see for example that
you are all
wearing your masks while here in this in
this press room this will all help us
fight the pandemic
any other questions for stefan on health
related issues
yes jessica
um i just wanted to ask given what's
happening in many parts of europe do you
think the vaccination strategy the eu's
vaccination strategies is working
stephen
well
again the the design of vaccination
strategies within the member states the
implementation of vaccination
vaccination strategies within the member
states are national competences is the
national contents this being said we
have set up at eu level our own
vaccination strategy which has led to
the availability of
billions of doses
we also see
remarkable increases in vaccination
rates and we also see reductions in
infections although of course this is
extremely
we have we are witnessing also
increases uh in some areas but i think
we could say that at the eu level the eu
vaccination strategy has definitely been
a success this does not mean that we
should
that there is no cause for concern there
is definitely cause of concern in
particular the fact that in some member
states vaccination rates are low that we
are witnessing indeed increases of
infections but this should not make us
forget that the role that we have played
here at european union is to make sure
that sufficient vaccines are available
vaccines that are safe
and effective effectiveness and safety
being
acknowledged by the european medicine
agency and so the work is as
eric said continues to focus on
vaccination and obviously taking into
account the different non-pharmaceutical
measures such as keeping distance and so
on thank you thank you very much
any other question on this for us today
mindaugus you have a question on the
kovid situation
yes i do indeed thank you for the floor
uh so could you just give us an update
about ema's approval for vaccinated
children for
from five years old because eu i think
is a little bit behind for example
america which is already doing that and
the other question or approve that
uh and the other question what is the
commission's position on national covet
health passes for
underage children for for young children
from 12 years old do you approve that or
do you think that that the health passes
should be only for
for for adults thank you
stefan can answer you on the first
question but the second question is um
should have been dealt with by christian
uh when he was here on the podium before
but stephen the first question yes i'm
afraid that on this first question you
should direct it to the european
medicine agency which is an independent
agency doing the assessment of the
vaccines also the except the assessment
of to what extent such vaccines can be
used in need for children from 5 to 11
or 6 to 11 depending on the on the the
type of vaccine so it is
in their hands but i understand that
evaluation is
ongoing but they can give you more
information on that thank you and on
your second question let me remind you
that
the regulation on the
eu digital kobe certificate
only concerns travel between member
states um i don't have at the top of my
mind um
what are the age uh
whether the age limits the lower age
limits for having a
a certificate but we can come back to
you on on that but
it is not
one of our
duties or prerogatives to basically
discuss the use of certificates within
the member states this is quite clearly
a member state prerogative
anna a question on the kovid situation
thank you very much uh good afternoon
everyone i have a question indeed
because what are the benefits of the
vaccination because on the example of
gibraltar where they had vaccinated not
only their own community 100
but also 18
of travelers so all together gibraltar
had
180 percent of vaccination plus
40 percent of boosters and now we heard
that they have to cancel the christmas
they cancel all the events and they are
measures in place and all happens as the
previous year so what are the benefits
of the vaccination
i think the benefits of the vaccination
are abundantly clear anna and i'm sure
stefan will have great pleasure in
reminding you what they are
uh indeed it is with a great pleasure
that i would like to stress you a couple
of very important things on the
effectiveness of the vaccines first
medical scientific data show that they
are extremely effective against severe
disease including hospitalizations and
deaths
and that the effectiveness remains high
at approximately 80 effectiveness
there is however some evidence of slight
decreasing protection in older frail
individuals and those with clinical risk
factors for more severe disease so this
means that the vaccines are achieving
what they are supposed to do
protecting people from getting severely
sick and dying from covet 19.
also in the past pandemic waves an
increase in infections meant also an
increase of hospitalizations and death
rates
in the current pandemic this is no
longer the case increasing infections
no longer entail necessarily more
hospitalizations and high higher death
rates this is another clear sign that
the vaccines are doing their job
according to the ecdc as well the
current increase in numbers that have
been reported numbers of report covet 19
cases we see that this is mainly driven
by and also affecting unvaccinated or
partially vaccinated individuals
and and i think i already referred to
this uh last week in its risk assessment
of september 2021 the ecdc had already
indicated that lifting protecting
protective measures
without having reached a sufficiently
high vaccination uptake of 75 percent
would lead to
a race arise i'm sorry in cases between
september and november and this is
exactly what we have been noticing in
some cases so the message remains very
clear as eric said vaccinate vaccinate
vaccinate but of course we also need to
bear in mind the importance of the
non-pharmaceutical interventions i hope
with this
anna that
your doubts have disappeared thank you
she nevertheless has a follow-up anna
uh thank you very much i appreciate what
you told but uh i addressed you with a
very specific question because uh
gibraltar community is the most
vaccinated community on the planet earth
they vaccinated hundred percent the
inhabitants plus 18 of travelers so they
are vaccinated
118
and still people are hospitalized
our people are dying and they have again
very severe sanitary measures in place
so what where's the benefit because
there is no uh there is no resolution of
the problem that i would like to say but
you repeat that we have to achieve a
maximum vaccination but what does it
bring to us to achieve it because people
of gibraltar achieved maximum
vaccination but they didn't um but they
didn't achieve the result because there
is no freedom there are measures in
place and the future is obscure because
boosters doesn't bring result either
anna we have never said that vaccination
on its own would solve the pandemic
so
that is a very simple answer to your uh
to your question
secondly the pandemic is not something
which is static
it is something that unfortunately is
evolving
and therefore the response
by the national health authorities and
at our level by the european commission
when it comes to providing
vaccines and ensuring that we have all
the necessary medical equipment et
cetera et cetera will also need to
continue to evolve but the question is
what would the situation be without
vaccines anna and the situation without
vaccines we saw it at the outbreak of
the pandemic
right remember what the months were
at beginning of 2020
the number of hospitalizations and
deaths that we had in europe and
therefore it is quite extraordinary
that after so much time
we still get this sort of question on
what are the benefits of vaccines think
about what the death toll would be
that people continue to be hospitalized
yes actually
many people who are hospitalized across
europe are people who are not vaccinated
um and if you look in percentage terms
i'm sure that you will see uh that the
that it is even more so the case
but the severe forms of the disease and
the death toll
by
you know by inhabitants
are now not comparable with what we had
at uh at the beginning of the pandemic
that being said we need to continue
being
careful so let me make it 100 clear anna
the commission is not changing its
position
when it comes and reaffirms its position
when it comes to recommending that
everybody including you gets vaccinated
[Music]
black
this is david price uh there's so many
davids uh can you hear me
yes david
okay thank you i'm
a bit confused at the beginning um
yes um i asked a question uh the
beginning of the year about uh natural
immunity
that this is uh about whether this the
commission considers this to be the best
option
um and i haven't heard
the word natural immunity being used
much
if at all in the
in this month since then
um
and at the moment we see as anna said
the
you've got countries
like gibraltar but you also have iceland
and israel which have
massive amounts of inoculations and yet
they have seem to have the
highest problem at the moment
so i'm wondering whether
and
if you compare sweden for example which
has got a different policy altogether
whether
the policy of the
inoculations should be reviewed
um
in the light of the present trends
so the two questions one on natural
immunity and second one on the fact that
the most highly inoculated countries are
having the biggest problems at the
moment look david and everybody i'm not
going to repeat this 100 times the
commission is recommending that
everybody gets vaccinated
full stop
on your other question on natural
immunity uh i have i don't know if uh
stefan has something to say and i'm not
actually sure what you're referring to
no but i admit that it's also for me not
entirely clear what you're referring to
but again when you look at the figures
when you look at the figures from ecdc
from emma you see that vaccination is
the best way the most important tool to
tackle this pandemic and therefore yes
we go full monty for vaccination
thank you
david you have a follow-up
t is when you get a mild form of the
disease
and then you don't have a problem later
on and the immunity lasts
upwards of a year or more
so it's obviously better if
people get
uh a mild form of the disease and then
uh have
something which is probably better than
inoculation of uh
an experimental um
uh
um
mr
m rna
product
um
and the the other factor is is that uh
if you look at the
death rates from kovid
certainly the
older people who are most um
vulnerable
uh
children um
do not have a problem yet they have
problems with vaccinations
um
the
the mortality rate of uh
uh with the
david is something like
between
95 uh for the older the seniors the very
old seniors
question please
well i'm going to transform this press
room into a debating society on um the
advantages and disadvantages of
vaccination let me make that abundantly
clear
we have a european medicines agency
that actually has provided and continues
to provide its analysis and we respect
what is said by the european medicine
agency so if you want to debate
the virtues or not of various types of
strategies to
fight the pandemic i invite you to do so
with
with the experts
of the european medicine agency here
we have set out our position and i'm
sorry but i'm not going to engage in
debates on this here
over the course of the of the midday
so if you have a very specific question
i'm happy to hear
go ahead
it does not seem to be the case thank
you
uh david carretta you had a question
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
to end the pandemic we need up to 70
percent of the population vaccinated
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scientific
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
yet you have the floor on this
if it's uncovered
yes hi okazinski from polish press
agents is also about
about covet
and
internal
commerce internal market commission
terry blatton
said
on march that europe can achieve hurt
immunity
against covet in mid july
so
i would like to ask whether europe
achieved already this
hurt immunity against virus
and if no
why or why
said so and the second issue what is the
definition of the
uh hurt immunity according to european
commission thank you
thank you thank you lukas look we do not
uh
use the concept of herd uh immunity but
i give the floor to stefanos
um i i think what was very important in
the messages that have been given the
past the importance of going forward
with vaccination we started uh beginning
of this year it began a bit slower
slowly and then it took uh it took uh
much more which
took some speed and it was very
important and this is what we had
already established the beginning of the
year that we would reach
70 in the meantime we have reached 75
the 70 was obviously based on input
scientific input that we received from
our scientific colleagues we continue to
follow the situation we see that we have
in some cases reached very high
vaccination rates but in other cases we
also see increasing infection rates and
on the basis of this situation we
continue to monitor the situation and
insist continue insisting on uh
vaccinations because this is what
matters that we continue our vaccination
and that we take the necessary
non-pharmaceutical measures to um to to
make progress
thank you lucas you have a follow-up
no sorry i don't have it i just forgot
just to speak
anna
i see you're asking for the floor again
i'll give you one question
it's on what you are my reflection and
question upon what you have said now
because basically
we are not talking about vaccinations so
much but about boosters because
countries majority of the countries
already reached the goal of 75
so it's their boosters and after
boosters most probably there are more
boosters so my question is
how it will reflect on fundamental
rights because now we live in modality
where human rights fundamental rights
are permanently restricted so does it
mean that these fundamental rights would
be restricted indefinitely as long as
the pandemic is going on and i would
like to remind you that for example
ebola has been lasting now for 40 years
that's why the concerns my concerns are
justified
thank you on boosters stefan
on boosters as we do with all other
topics in the area of health policy and
in particular our vaccination strategy
we listen to the science we listen to
emma we listen to ecdc
emma has made an opinion as you know
about boosters it has made the
distinction between two types of
boosters
additional doses that are given to
people with weaker immunity systems
older frey individuals that may be
more more prone to
to infections we also see as i said
before a slightly waning effectiveness
of the vaccines given to these more
frail individuals on the other and for
these boosters the ema has given a very
clear opinion that such boosters
can indeed be considered to increase um
the
the protection of these people
in addition emma has made a very clear
opinion or guidance on additional doses
to anybody else so people who are not in
this category of frail
weaker immunity system where in that
case also emma has said that
administering a additional a booster
rather
six months after the first after the
full vaccination may indeed be
considered to strengthen or to improve
uh or to reduce i would say the the risk
of infections and this is what what
we're following and these are the
recommendations that have been made by
emma and it's up to the member states to
uh to to see how they integrate this in
their vaccination policies and see to
what extent they want indeed to go ahead
with boosters for their uh for for
certain target groups uh uh in their
population thank you
and on the issue of fundamental rights
anna i already gave you an answer when
you asked this question some days ago on
tuesday i believe and i have nothing to
add to what i said at that point in time
[Music]
we have to move on it's already been
an hour that we are here so
um we will now close the chapter on
kovid and move on to
other issues
and i give the floor to
ana ana pinto who had been asking for
the floor before go ahead
good afternoon everybody i'm sorry my
camera is not working
i have a question on environment
it's a report issued this morning based
on official data
revealing that
last year uh
thousands of tons of banned pesticides
which are very very poisonous for bees
were exported by member states
and i'm sure you haven't had the time to
see the report yet but i understand that
the eu chemicals strategy for
sustainability that's
from october 2020
in in that strategy the european
commission committed to prevent
the export of hazardous chemicals banned
in the eu
so i'd like to know if there has been
taken any actions um for implementing
this objective
and also if i may i have a second
question yesterday the commission
announced a plan to ban imports of agri
commodities linked to deforestation
and that is regardless if the removal of
trees are considered legal in the
exporter country
so i wonder if the same criteria should
not be applied in this case to i mean
if a chemical is banned in the european
union because it killed the bees
does the commission consider acceptable
that member states exported and poisoned
the bees in other countries thank you
very much
thank you i'm not aware of this report
but vivian perhaps you can
specify once again what our rules are
thanks very much and thanks anna for the
question
it's a lot of very many different
aspects that you raised so if you could
really please just send it let's talk
afterwards also so that i can come back
on each and every
uh
part of the question that you had but
just to be very clear where we are on
the
on the waste management indeed yesterday
we came with this proposal of an amended
regulation to make sure that we don't
export our waste to countries which
cannot deal with it so in our proposal
we we are now
proposing to have
concrete
limitations and making sure that the
countries which receive the waste have
capabilities to deal with them if they
don't they wouldn't have it on the
chemicals indeed last year we had a
proposal also on banning the hazardous
waste being
being sent to countries which are not
capable of dealing with that
when it comes to the pesticides that's
something which in our farm to fork
strategy we have
taken the commitment to bring down the
use of pesticides considerably i think
by half by 2030
and
and the work on that one is ongoing with
our
with our member states so all of those
topics that you raise they're very much
linked of course to our
objectives of the green deal it is on
one side to become carbon neutral which
is the key aim but it's also to make
sure that our environment is clean that
we don't that our food is clean that we
are we are taking care of
of of all those things and making sure
that we don't
have any
any more pesticides that are strictly
necessary don't have the antibiotics so
on so all of those things we'll be happy
to discuss in more detail if we can get
back to you afterwards thank you
okay thank you very much vivian it's um
one o'clock we will now move to the
press conference on the review of
competition policy thank you very much
see you tomorrow